[Música]
Bienvenidos a este nuevo programa de
medio ambiente yo soy María Clara calle
china está induciendo la lluvia para
enfrentar la sequía más larga de su
historia en la provincia de en el este
están lanzado pequeñas Varillas de
yoduro de plata a las nubes que ayudan a
formar cristales de hielo para que la
humedad sea más pesada Y hacer que
llueva más rápido pero la técnica no es
nueva el país tiene el mayor programa
del mundo para modificar el clima y ha
experimentado con ingeniería
meteorológica desde 1958 la técnica la
usaron en los Olímpicos de Medellín para
acelerar la lluvia y garantizar un
tiempo seco en la clausura de los juegos
recientemente el consejo de estado se
trazó que para 2025 cubrirán 5,5
millones de kilómetros cuadrados con su
programa esto es más de la mitad de toda
China y un área más grande que India
y ahora vuelven a usar el yoduro de
plata para enfrentar la sequía Y es que
esta completa más de 70 días superando
el récord de 62 que duró en 2013 como lo
explica la administración meteorológica
de acuerdo con el monitoreo reciente del
centro climático de Beijing teniendo en
cuenta la intensidad promedio de las
olas de calor la escala de impacto y la
duración la intensidad combinada de las
olas de calor en las regiones de China
que ha habido desde el 13 de junio ha
sido la más fuerte desde que comenzó el
registro de observaciones meteorológicas
el calor es tanto que 10 provincias
chinas han registrado sus niveles
récords con temperaturas que superan los
40 grados Celsius las zonas más
afectadas son el sureste y el Noroeste
con estragos más que visibles en las
provincias de
Esta última es la que produce más
energía hidroeléctrica en toda china
pero el tiempo seco ha hecho que sus
reservas bajen a más de la mitad al
punto que el gobierno local ordenó que
cientos de industrias pararan sus
operaciones durante casi una semana
incluidos los proveedores de grandes
compañías como Toyota foxcon y tesla
esto para priorizar la energía de los
hogares en donde se recomendó que los
aires acondicionados no se pusieran por
debajo de los 26 grados Celsius para
ahorrar el suministro Y ante la escasez
china ha aumentado su producción de
Carbón lo que afecta su promesa de
lograr la neutralidad de carbono para
2060 las hidroeléctricas de sichuan
están afectadas por los niveles
históricamente bajos del río Yangzi el
más largo de Asia y el tercero más largo
del mundo en una de sus llanuras está el
lago pollang que es vital en el
suministro de agua y que ahora se secó
parcialmente al pasar de 4.000
kilómetros cuadrados a menos 600 el
nivel del yangtsé bajo tanto que incluso
develo una isla sumergida con tres
esculturas budistas de más de 600 años
de antigüedad
antes el agua era de más de Tres metros
en la temporada he trabajado aquí más de
una década y nunca había visto el nivel
del agua tan bajo y hablando de récords
Brasil tiene uno y no precisamente por
sequías según un estudio de www.f este
es el país que más importa carne de
tiburón y un reporte de encargado por sí
shepard Brasil sostiene que también es
donde más consumen este pez Solo que el
70% de los brasileños comen tiburón sin
saberlo mientras que la falta de
regulación tiene consecuencias sobre la
conservación de la especie Fanny luter
nos cuenta es Día de Mercado en Gloria
el centro de Río de Janeiro en los
puestos de las pescaderías su aleta
llama la atención y su carne es muy
popular
por favor
cuánto cuesta
7 dólares el kilo tiburón también
llamado cazón capturada en las costas
brasileñas o importada la carne de
tiburón es una de las más baratas y a
los brasileños les encanta son los
mayores consumidores del mundo según la
ong
el cazón es delicioso su carne es tierna
Blanca es un pescado muy popular aquí en
Brasil según seapbert el 70% de los
brasileños come tiburón sin saberlo
natalielle lleva varios años denunciando
su venta en los supermercados del país
entramos con la cámara de manera
discreta de las 150 especies de
tiburones que se pescan en Brasil casi
la mitad está en peligro de extinción
azul desafortunadamente todavía se
permite pescarlo
entonces presiones son ejercidas para
colocar esta especie en la lista de
protección y no poder pescar la masa
Pero esto tampoco resolvería el problema
de la comercialización y de la
importación
un peligro para la especie pero también
para los humanos en este laboratorio
este investigador universitario analiza
la toxicidad de la carne de tiburón como
la que se compra en el mercado de Gloria
Cuanto más alta es la posición de la
especie en la cadena alimentaria más
alto son los niveles de contaminación
por mercurio los últimos estudios
realizados aquí son sorprendentes el 54%
de la carne de tiburón analizada
contiene niveles de mercurio superiores
a un miligramo por kilo
yo creo que hay en Brasil una tradición
de explotación minera con mercurio
histórica
entonces seguramente Esto está
contribuyendo a hacer que la
contaminación en las costas brasileñas
sea elevada
y esto independientemente de si el
tiburón vive en las costas o en aguas
más profundas
la conta por mercurio e insecticidas en
los suelos y los ríos brasileños no
conoce fronteras y se extiende en todos
los océanos a pesar de todo esto las
autoridades brasileñas no han tomado
medidas para regular la pesca o la
importación de tiburones hasta aquí
nuestra Crónica de medio ambiente pueden
ver este y más programas 24.com nos
vemos
[Música]